[Music]
hey
you guys yeah i'm in here talking to my
new [ __ ] louie
man settings on my tablet sure it was
okay
go ahead put that on with his gayness
okay go on with your gayness yeah why is
this thing why is this thing this this
[ __ ] chair is always like in a weird
spot
it's not it's in the same spot it's
always moves all the time
my camera angles are all [ __ ] crazy
change is bad
i don't like it you do look pretty okay
all right today we're going to talk
about
sweet and sour sauce chinese stuff
or chinese american fast food it's
probably the same in
in europe pretty much you know and it's
probably the same wherever you go in the
world
none of this [ __ ] is stuck in chinese it
was stuff that chinese immigrants made
up for white folks
here eat this it's good that's
good some of the stuff that they sell us
like
um what general sews chicken
is based on a real recipe but it's not
chinese
okay didn't we see a whole documentary
about that yeah it's actually really
interesting
it came from taiwan i believe and it
came from from a hotel
and we're talking about general so's
chicken it was a hotel recipe
only a couple chefs knew
that knew the actual sauce it was
classified that [ __ ] was classified
every every version of general shows
chicken you've had is a copy it's a fake
nobody knows what it originally tasted
like it was similar
but not really there's only a couple of
guys still alive that knew what the
original tasted like and they tasted to
go no that's not it
no that's not it but they're not going
to tell you whatever i'll tell you what
it is you know well they will tell you
but then they'd have to kill you
it's like these [ __ ] kung fu
[ __ ]
special [ __ ] attacks and [ __ ] oh you
got to go to special school
[Laughter]
they these guys tend not to write things
down they're
uh uh they're they're cooks that
have [ __ ] memorized in their head and
they won't give it to anybody else
that's where they are so eventually the
original
general sews chicken will be lost to
history i mean
because they're [ __ ] selfish they
won't write that [ __ ] down but you know
what
[ __ ] steal my recipe same thing about
coca-cola though nobody knows what the
original recipe was
i mean the recipe for coca-cola you have
now is not the original one that came
out in the 1800s it's been changed
several times
but today i'm going to talk about sweet
and sour
sauce which is the basis for sweet and
sour chicken and sweet and sour pork
sweet and sour shrimp sweet and sour
shrimp all right
my friend and i'm gonna talk about how
to fry
the meat you know what kind of a tempura
coating is going to be on it
um there's a couple different variations
for the sauce
a couple different variations for the
batter a couple different variations for
the damn fruits and vegetables that go
in there
but everybody knows sweet and sour sweet
and sour is uh
legend man legendary
very popular too and you taste it and it
tastes like some exotic you know man
that's that's
where do they buy that you know when you
see the
red the the when you see the recipe
and when you understand the ingredients
you laugh okay because there's nothing
exotic about that at all all right
so i'm going to start off with a very
basic
um outline for
uh sweet and sour sauce you can
find and i'll give you as an example of
where to start
you don't have to write this down these
recipes are all over the internet
but there's some tricks to them okay
there's a trick to working with this
stuff
okay now i'm gonna go over to i got one
of them right here
i'm gonna read it out this is just a
basic example
of what a sweet and sour sauce is like
okay this why is this [ __ ] so big
that's what she said i
[Laughter]
yeah you know you might be slightly
africanized
pull that big [ __ ] black snake out of
there that's why they called it the
mississippi white snake man
it was just a different version of the
black one
genie loves it when i talk dirty like
that
okay these are very basic
ingredients on a um
sweet and sour sauce okay ketchup
sugar vinegar soy sauce
corn starch pineapple juice and a little
bit of oil
yep that's it that's it okay so you're
going wait a minute hold on
ketchup sugar vinegar soy sauce corn
starch and pineapple juice
yes that's all it is but that's the very
basic one
okay if you want one that is
that real electric red
it's maraschino cherry juice yeah mixed
in
with the um with the uh
the pineapple juice the pineapple juice
is coming out of the pineapple can that
you're gonna
put the pineapple slices into the sauce
with and sometimes you'll see that that
sauce has little
cherries in it that's because if you're
going to use cherry juice you might as
well throw some cherries in there too
okay yeah i mean i feel like we usually
put maraschino cherries in it while we
make it
the secret to this you take
a quarter cup of sugar a quarter cup of
white vinegar
and a quarter cup of ketchup and a
tablespoon of soy sauce and you put it
in a pan you heat it up
okay and then in a little ramekin you
put like
a tablespoon and a half corn starch in
there squirt some water in there and
stir it until it's a milky paste
don't actually like a milky substance
you don't want paste you want it to be
kind of
watery so it mixes in there and then
once it's in there
you're gonna your thickening agent in
all that chinese food is always that
always a heaping tablespoon of corn
starch and a ramekin put some water in
it
turn it into something like milk and
pour that into the sauce
and it will it will thicken almost
instantly
then once you have that pour in the
entire can
of pineapples with the juice
put that in there put about six seven
maraschino cherries and a couple
tablespoons of the damn
cherry juice in it and it will be red
it'll be [ __ ] great
all right now a couple things you might
want to add into there
you might want to add some water
chestnuts you might want to add a
a diced up bell pepper maybe a green one
or a red one or a yellow one or green
yellow and red if you want to get fancy
if you want to get a super color you
want to use super colorful you put it
all in there
i like bell pepper yeah and then once
that's and just
let it simmer all right let it simmer
it'll be in
make sure you got the thickness right if
it's too thick add a little bit of
water to thin it okay and just put it on
the back
burner okay now
just keep it warm now you now
after that you're going to be worried
about your meat all right
you're going to you're worried about
your meat yeah i'm always worried about
me
that's got a lot of meat to take care of
you got to maintain that
as previously mentioned smooth it out
you know
smooth it out yes jenny for help jenny
you gotta
get your hands clean yeah hold this
smooth this [ __ ] out for me you know let
me put something on the watch
it might be some crazy [ __ ] like that
but anyway
you're so distractible yeah see anyway
getting sexual getting sexual with all
that testosterone
so then after that all right you're
going to want to worry about
what meat you're going to use it could
be shrimp it could be
pork it could be cubed pork tenderloin
it could be
a cubed um chicken breast
it could be cubed up uh chicken thigh it
could be human if you could get it if
it's hungry
and that [ __ ] civilization starts
collapsing you start eating some
neighbors
[Laughter]
sweetness our neighbors yeah long pork
so you get your meat cubed up all right
there's a couple different ways you can
do this the easiest way is once the meat
is cubed up
i would probably put a little bit of soy
sauce in it and mix it all
up and just let it marinate for a few
minutes take a piece of meat and throw
it in a bowl
and inside the bowl you actually have a
bowl
filled with cornstarch and just roll it
so each one of them is covered
and put it all on a plate until they're
all covered all right
and then take them and put them in a
frying pan with a little bit of oil in
the bottom of them flip them over
fry them all right that's the easiest
way there's another way
what what that will yield is that will
yield a crust
that is uh kinda chewy slash
crispy it'll almost kind of be like the
crust on a
fried chicken not quite but kinda
you can season it if you want to in in
that corn starch you can put
some gin a powdered ginger in there
that's pretty good
uh maybe a little bit of salt and white
pepper all right like that chinese white
pepper
that might be good too but most of the
time in these restaurants
it's plain it's just plain corn flour
you roll meat through it and put it in
the fryer
there's another way though you can do
something called a slurry
all right in the bowl of meat
you can put the cornstarch directly in
it
and you can put water in there with it
and just all stir it with your hand and
it becomes a gloopy
slurry and you can pick up each piece of
meat out of there one by one and drop
them in a frying pan that'll also work
some people like that one it gives a
little bit of a different texture
okay now here's the now if you like one
that's like a tempura which is a
a um a batter that kinda
blows up and becomes light and fluffy
and crisp on the outside kind of like a
tempura
you'll see this sometimes in a in a
chinese restaurant where they want the
piece of meat to look bigger than it
really is
you guys know what i'm talking about
when you're trying to get the piece of
meat to look a little bit bigger
you're going when you're going to the
club and you take a rolled up sock
try to make it look a little bit bigger
than it did well they had they do that
sometimes
okay and what they'll do is they'll
they'll make the slurry bowl with the
meat in it
it's got the corn starch and the water
any kind of seasoning if you want
seasoning in there or not
you take that and you add a little bit
of flour to it
and then you add say maybe like an egg
or maybe two eggs depending on how big
that
your there's a certain consistency
you're looking for a lot of this shit's
just kind of done by hand it's not
science it's art so you put in there and
a whipped egg
a beaten egg and stir it all around and
when you take that and drop it into
into oil like uh in a to deep fry it it
doesn't have to be deep fried it could
be pan fried too
and about a you know uh
maybe half an inch oil it will kind of
inflate and blow up a little bit
it'll get bigger and it'll kind of have
a
uh i'm sure you guys have seen that
crust before you've seen it right jay
where yeah
like it's like fluffy yeah that's what
they have in the uh
at the uh wine i'll have that koi wand
yeah yeah that's just flour and egg yolk
excuse me flour and beaten egg into the
damn slurry it'll do that
okay and uh
it's easy to do you just have to there's
a lot of tutorials
that shows novices on how this is done
if you don't have the confidence most of
this [ __ ] is confidence
confidence prep work and preparation you
know you you're pre
you're making things ahead um
now in a restaurant when they were
making when you're making the
um the sauce the sweet and sour sauce
chances are it doesn't have any of the
vegetables or the fruit in it
they'll sometimes keep that separate all
right
so it's just a red clear sauce
okay and now you can store it like that
for a long period of time
and usually what they'll do is they'll
put it in a squirt bottle like you know
a squirt bottle for ketchup yeah put it
in that they'll cut the tip of it off so
a bunch of it comes out at once
and when they're making a meal in a wok
they'll fry the
the meat okay they'll have that ready
they'll put that in the wok and then
they'll just squirt the sauce in there
and throw the vegetables on top the
sauce and toss it and then plate it
you know that way you can have
you can make a bunch of sauce up like a
gallon two gallons of that sauce up and
you can keep it in a walk-in freezer or
a walk-in refrigerator or a reach-in
refrigerator
and it'll stay indefinitely and then you
can add whatever fruits and vegetables
you want to it to make that one
sauce be three or four different things
depending on what the meal is
you know what i mean yeah efficiency is
key efficiency everything is
mixing and matching and modifying and
the sweet and sour sauce too
is used on different meats too it's like
i said so it's used in different
slightly different
dishes yeah and uh when they're using it
on different dishes it might have
different
um a different uh uh
fruits or vegetables in it yeah i don't
know what it is it was a pork it was a
chicken you know
it all depends on what that kitchen is
doing
i think that's pretty much it's
interesting because when
we get when i get that at like koi won
or something like that
it's usually basically just tempora
chicken or pork
pieces yeah with the sauce on the side
and that's
it i mean when we make it at home we
usually we don't usually deep fry it we
usually pan fry it
and um we don't you know we do less the
tempura
thing and more just like the regular you
know just dredging it through the thing
and then but you know then we just serve
it with right with all the fruits and
vegetables like over rice or something
well the reason why they're doing that
at koi won which is a buffet is that you
do not want that sauce sitting on
tempura and meat all day long because
it'll just become super super [ __ ]
soggy yeah
you want it to be crisp yeah and um
they do the they do kind of like a
tempura that has egg but egg yolk or
egg in it and flour and it kind of puffs
up
i don't really like that i like i like
the pork to hat to be
just rolled in in
just roll it in corn starch season's
cornstarch maybe yeah and it gives you
like a smaller
piece of meat which i know some girls
like a small
it gives you a smaller bite some girls
want a smaller bite
it makes it more compact and it's kind
of chewy
and crispy yeah i don't like the
fluffiness that much some people like it
just but
when usually when you see the fluffy one
that's on a piece of chicken
yeah that's usually i don't know if i've
ever seen i've seen shrimp done that way
too i don't know if i've ever had
like pork done like that though they're
trying to make the piece of shrimp look
bigger
and cooking time on shrimp is very
uh short so
i don't know it must work out a little
bit better i've never really done done
the shrimp versions myself
because usually i wouldn't waste shrimp
if i had shrimp i'd i'd probably be
doing something southern style you know
like boiling it
shrimp salad type deal you know um
but no this is how it's done i got
people in there saying i've never tried
this before i want to try it
mango batches you always want to try
biggest sweet sour dude it's so easy
it is very easy and there's a there's
and and
the recipe that i gave that i quoted the
one with the ketchup
um in it is actually a complicated one
some of them don't have the ketchup and
some of them don't have the
the um the sweet the the soy sauce in it
it's just vinegar sugar
um uh pineapple juice
and uh what else do they sometimes
you'll see what i'm talking about some
of them are just
really really basic there's not much
there
and surprisingly some of the ones that
don't have many ingredients on it taste
pretty damn good because that's what
you're used to getting
those those fast food chinese
restaurants are
they're masters at skimping to give you
as little as possible
when it comes to uh what what the
ingredients were
i wonder what they put in mcdonald's
sweet and sour sauce like their dipping
sauce for the
for the for the nugs it doesn't have
that that it doesn't have
probably not anything in it i don't know
is it a basic one
it's more like yellow it's like
yellowish orange that's what i feel like
yeah the if it's just pineapple it's
kind of yellow
if you add okay once you make that basic
pineapple base and you add a couple like
i said
uh three quarters of a cup of
just regular [ __ ] heinz ketchup in it
you know you can squirt it by hand you
don't have to measure the [ __ ] once
once you've made it a few times you go
you can do it by eye
and as long as you taste it and you get
the good balance of sweet and sour that
you want that's all you're trying to do
yeah those those precise measurements
are just like a kind of like a to help
you
like a rule of thumb that's more or less
what they're talking about
but you can adjust them a little bit to
get a taste that you want
you're trying to get a resonant
frequency
between sweet the sweetness of the sugar
and the sourness of the the vinegar and
then you're blending in
kind of the tartness of pineapple
and but then in a weird way you coming
in from another direction
if you decide to add soy sauce to it
it makes it a little bit salty which is
like a flavor enhancer on all of them
and then the tomato you know ketchup
goes in there and it just kind of
you'll see if you add them in there in
the right
order like leaving out the soy
and leaving out the tomato ketchup just
taste it first and you'll see what i'm
talking about and then you add the soy
and then taste it again you'll see you
go oh okay yeah it changed it
and then add the tomato ketchup it'll
just boom
it'll be different each time it's kind
of like they're separate sauces
they don't taste alike kind of but each
one you will recognize
because you've had them all if you've
been eating chinese food you've had a
mall
there's only about four or five
variations and chances are if you're
lived long enough
you've had every version of it and i
should add too that it depends
uh particularly if you're in the u.s it
depends on which brand of ketchup you're
using because some of them are sweeter
than others
yeah you want to use you know if you
want it to be like the american version
you want to use an american ketchup like
heinz or hunts
yeah uh heinz is the most common here
hunts is considered to be kind of like
the bastard
stepchild of decent american ketchup
[Laughter]
now when i was talking to chantal that's
you know when she was making that
catfish i said you know i just like side
of ketchup you know that should come
with a side of ketchup she kind of
looked at me
yeah it's kind of cheap but i forgot to
mention that she should just try to make
her own ketchup because i used to do
that for that
that place out there in [ __ ] gulfport
mississippi we made our own ketchup made
our own mayonnaise made our own mustard
those are pretty easy to make easy to
make but man it's so much better making
your own
custom ketchup and then some of that
[ __ ] was made with uh
you know was designed to be made with
brown sugar and and
jack daniel's whiskey in it man it's
[ __ ] really good
well anything's better with jack
[Laughter]
that's you know it's a bold statement
i'm sticking but i'm staying i'm
sticking with it
i would imagine that probably in most of
europe you can get decent ketchup now
you couldn't get it in brazil when i was
there back in the 80s but maybe things
have changed yeah you have like that
watery [ __ ] that was kind of
watering it was [ __ ] orange terrible
and uh it's kind of like the equivalent
of franco-american
as opposed to chef boyardee yeah it's
like something not a damn can of
spaghetti or something yeah
so nasty and it was like artificially
colored you know i mean like
you could tell that color was not
natural and i was like
there's in that big old jar there's
probably that
in that whole bottle there's probably
maybe a half a teaspoon of tomato in
there
rest of it was something else it wasn't
we don't know what
but it wasn't tomatoes yeah they were
trying to make that [ __ ] last
talk a little bit about uh duck sauce
like while we're on these because it's
very easy i love duck sauce
i could just like drink that right out
of the packet yeah
the easiest way to make there the best
way to make that is you want some kind
of preserves like apricot preserves
that's usually the best one yeah i think
that's the most common
cup it's apricot preserves and vinegar
all right and you just add vinegar and
sometimes brown sugar depends on what
you're making
and you can make it as you need it take
a couple teaspoons of
or a couple tablespoons of apricot
preserve put it in a ramekin
put a little bit of um white vinegar in
there with it take a couple tablespoons
uh maybe like a half a half a teaspoon
of um
soy sauce and uh maybe like a
half a teaspoon of brown sugar mix
stir it together put it in a microwave
for a minute
and then stir it again then let it cool
and when it cools it'll congeal back
down into
real good duck sauce
now some apri the apricot preserves is
the
is the cheapest way all right the
[ __ ]
best way i've ever had it though was
just substitute the apricot preserves
for [ __ ]
orange marmalade and that was really
good oh i bet that would be good
orange barbell it was [ __ ] kick ass
that's my favorite thing to put on egg
rolls
yeah is that duck sauce that you get
from the chinese recipe and if you like
um
chinese mustard it's nothing but
powdered mustard
powdered mustard with water in it that's
all it is
mangoes burn you up mango says i think
we call duck sauce plum sauce
plum sauce yeah yeah yeah same thing
it's like that
that orangey yellow gold they will call
it anything
orange sauce plug duck sauce something
sauce
nut sauce they just caught any kind of
slice
the most common things is it's not plum
because plum preserves are harder to
find and they're more expensive and you
it's hard to tell them apart from
apricot apricot
preserves or apricot jam
here in the united states it's just
cheap as [ __ ] i mean they'll give it
away
you can get a big old jar of it for like
a dollar and
from that you'll you can make a lot of
it now it's kind of a lost art
because most of these chinese places
nowadays are carry out
so they want to give it to you in a
single serving plastic
packet because that's easy for them but
that tastes like [ __ ]
the old school stuff was in a jar on the
table when you went in there to sit down
and eat and you'd spoon it on yeah that
was the best stuff and that's it
they made it the way i just told you it
was either apricot
every now and then it was it was it was
orange marmalade
and maybe sometimes it might have been
something plum but
that was probably back in the 70s i
can't recall ever
having it i mean we have plums here but
i feel like it's not
used in a lot of stuff you'd have to
find plum preserves
and that's going to be some kind of rare
food the food service industry like
cisco and all these [ __ ]
probably not gonna have that on the
order list that'd be something you have
to source yourself
as a restaurant owner and and they're
not gonna do that they're gonna they're
gonna take the the cheapest easiest
thing to get their hands on to just make
a condiment
they're just making a condiment it's
free yeah i'm going to spend a lot of
money on it
i mean i feel like maybe particularly in
florida if you're making it down here
you probably want to use orange
marmalade because we have [ __ ]
oranges all over the world
this was that was like one of the best
ones just you tend not to have it on
hand when you need it
that's true yeah i mean [ __ ] man we're
just the the path that we walk on behind
our house there's like little tangerines
or
tangelos or whatever they are just
growing on a little [ __ ] wild tree
back there
you can pluck them off and eat them and
they're good yeah but you know
don the bomb says dom's double entendres
or oh
right i did i didn't expect this show
was just gonna be so oh i'm getting all
you know
mango said we have bram wells here in
the uk the bastard ketchup of all
ketchups
tasty too i don't remember if i had that
that's i remember seeing that brand in
the stores when i was over there but i
don't
remember if i had anything with it on
there you know what i mean i would yeah
for
um you know mango i would suggest
getting on the internet
and finding a badass american recipe
for homemade ketchup american style
ketchup
we're putting one in the cookbook yeah
well there is one there is one in the
cookbook
putting one i already put it in there
it's already
and you know it's not very expensive to
make it's it's easy to make and
you make a pretty decent batch of it you
know in a pot
and then store it okay good bad really
good
you know what i like i like curry
ketchup yeah you make ketchup and then
throw some [ __ ] curry powder in there
yeah which is always really good on
french fries
a good homemade ketchup is a base for a
bunch of things
you know yeah you can you can take that
and then like you said you could add
whiskey to it cook it some more or like
you said you could put some curry in it
cook it you know paprika and stuff and
cook it
paprika yeah you could probably put
chipotle in it probably really good
yeah if you want like spicy yeah if you
want like spicy ketchup
because i feel like that's kind of like
well like i told you this place i used
to go to in new york city i don't know
if it's there anymore but um
palm frite and they used to do this
twice cooked
fries you know they were real crispy and
you just got a big cone of them and then
they had like
40 bajillion different sauces yeah and
they had a really good curry ketchup
they had like some spicy ketchup they
had like spicy mayo's they had like all
different kind of [ __ ] that you could
all kind of malt vinegars you could like
dip the fries and that was all they did
was fries and
all the different kinds of sauces and it
was really really good now when you guys
start sourcing these recipes make sure
you know just
look at the damn list of ingredients
make sure you guide everything before
you go
um you might want to start off with a
real simple one first
one it doesn't have a whole lot of
ingredients in it taste it see if that's
what you were talking about if not
modify it with some of the other stuff
a lot of them will be missing things
like
ketchup or missing things like soy sauce
that's not mentioned
but yeah put that in there put it all in
there but
put all that [ __ ] in there esther said
my uncle made barbecue sauce with
ketchup
yeah yeah you can do it yeah not all of
them have that but a lot of variations
you can
you got to know what you're doing and
there's certain certain flavors you'll
never get by doing it that way
it's been a long time since i've made
that i used to make that all the time
yeah been years um
but um also there's going to be a big
variation of
what kind of vegetables go in there like
they'll talk about
putting pineapple in it they'll talk
about maybe putting a couple cherries in
it
and a lot of them won't mention the
cherry juice a maraschino cherry some
don't mention that
yeah that's how you get that bright
electric red color
and it tastes really good um
but some of the cheaper ones don't have
it so just pay attention to what it is
you're making
all right a lot of them won't mention
water chestnuts
no water chestnuts should go in it so
should
peppers green pepper red pepper yellow
pepper yeah big chunks big chunks and
big chunks of onion too yeah big chunks
of onion and don't overcook them don't
don't overcook those
so crispy you want them still kind of
crispy don't overcook them don't don't
cook them till they're clear
cook it till the onions white yeah yeah
you'll see it's good like that good and
it's good you just pile it until you put
some rice in the bottom you pile all the
the meat and the veggies and the
cherries and the pineapples on there
it's really good no
sauce you're trying to go low calorie
and trying to get rid of these carbs
you can eliminate rice yeah you don't
have to have it all right you don't have
to eat it the way it is
you there you can just eat the sauce on
them on those meat and vegetables that's
it you don't need the rice
um rice is filler and i remember when i
was trying to cut calories down
we'd go to we'd go to koi won and i'd
eat everything on that [ __ ] buffet
except the rice
rice and noodles and and man i'd walk
out of there
feeling strong just especially if you're
just punishing them for putting shrimp
out
if you put shrimp out around me i'ma
[ __ ] punish you we just
have to like fight over like the [ __ ]
boiled shrimp because i'm like i'm gonna
eat all the no i'm gonna eat all that
i'm gonna make you pay if you put that
put that out there on a buffet i'm gonna
[ __ ] you
i'm gonna eat more shrimp than you've
ever [ __ ] seen
and if i pay for those crab legs extra
to do that all you can eat crab legs
that's what's going to happen i'm going
to sit there and just eat all the damn
crap
fighting them damn crabs give me every
single crab leg you have in this joint
[Laughter]
crab skeletons on over here you know
chinese waitress look at me like i'm
crazy and i'm just not yeah i'm gonna
eat all your food
i want some more crabs you said it was
all i can eat yeah i can eat i
you know i can eat i can eat more
it's all protein i don't know where i
have a damn soup bowl
filled with [ __ ] melted butter i'm
not worried about cholesterol when i'm
eating crab legs
well yeah that's the thing duck in that
[ __ ] crab and i mean [ __ ] if
i could just go i could just go to the
chinese buffet and just eat
cold boiled shrimp and uh cocktails and
cut and
a big thing of cocktail sauce yeah and i
could just eat a [ __ ] pile of that
[ __ ] i don't even need any other stuff
although i do like some of these i like
the pepper steak i like some of the fish
dishes that they have when we were when
i was stationed in egypt you know they
started giving out the british were
cooking and they
and and the israelis were supplying all
the food
and uh every now and then we'd have
lobster day and they'd come out with
these lobster thermadors
and they were small lobster tails yeah
but most of these dudes you know
they mostly dudes in the infantry you
know what i mean they
they come from the hood they won't eat
they won't eat a [ __ ] lobster they
don't need to keep looking like
that looks like a bug i mean that's a
bug someone needs to be perfectly honest
so me and every other damn red delicious
delicious bug
i mean all the rednecks would be out
there we'd have whole [ __ ] because
the cooks would be like eat all these
lobsters
they'd tell us to eat them all did we
not let these things because they didn't
pay for them
yeah they were given to us and you know
they're just end up throwing them all
away
so we took two whole [ __ ] tables and
pushed them together
all right everybody had a bowl of them
uh what do you call it
cocktail no [ __ ] no melted butter
everybody had a bowl of melted butter
and then we had whole trays
you know plastic serving trays filled
with [ __ ]
lobster tails on there all right another
ones that were just with the empty hulls
and i think man i must have ate i would
just got
maybe a dozen of them damn tails one
time i mean i was just
they weren't they were only about you
know four inches long about two inches
wide but we were just
trying to tear them up and people were
looking at us like we were gross
ten of us just sitting there eating a
whole company's worth
[Laughter]
people looking at you like you're in
[ __ ] dawn of the dead
i don't know man they just some people
didn't grow up around that kind of
seafood
i guess they won't eat they would get
one time they gave us [ __ ] deep fried
oysters
with lemon butter oh and you guys
wouldn't eat that
so i must have gained [ __ ] 10 pounds
big oysters man they were [ __ ] big
oysters they
dipped them in them cornmeal i like them
done
i like them done on the grill too yeah
they're good like that too yeah
deep fried we're sitting there as [ __ ]
man just [ __ ] blown up
[Laughter]
i know i'm gaining weight just you
talking about it
all right let's see what everybody's
saying
yeah grantha's hammer said goose breast
wrapped in bacon with a sliver of red
onion and jalapeno pepper inside
sounds good on the grill for five
minutes good stuff you could cook
you could cook a cat turd this way yeah
yeah
said i was surprised that israelis
supplied lobster it's not kosher i don't
know it might be
because you could they were giving us we
went uh
went to a lot and when they had a pizza
hut there
and uh really the only meat you could
get on a pizza
is like they had cheese on it was uh
shrimp
so we had shrimp pizza i don't know if
the lobster is kosher i honestly kind of
like shrimp pizza i know people are kind
of grossed out by it
but i mean i've had shrimp pizza before
and it's for it's perfectly crumbling
they were eating they were eating
shrimp so if they were eating shrimp i
don't see why they wouldn't eat lobster
yeah or another thing is is another
thing is that maybe uh
they produce lobster and sell it but
they don't eat it themselves yeah
you know just because they can't eat it
doesn't mean they wouldn't make it
um and they also the israelis also
supplied all our ice cream man israeli
ice cream was really
good real good what flavors was it
all the normal stuff vanilla uh vanilla
chocolate strawberry uh
they had uh what do you call it
pistachio they had
you know like vanilla with a chocolate
swirl in it and
stuff like that just kind of pretty
standard but it's good
real good quality it's kind of like
bluebell
oh okay so you got some good [ __ ] like
bluebell pretty good
there's bluebell and then there's blue
bunny yeah blue bunny's not as good blue
bell's good though yeah
if you guys want good ice cream we have
a company here in the south called blue
bell
[ __ ] great better than any of that
[ __ ] ben and jerry's [ __ ]
it doesn't they have a bunch of flavors
but they tend to be kind of simple they
got a nana pudding flavor
[ __ ] great but it's really
really rich it stretches it's kind of
chewy
it's very very rich they've really
expanded their flavor line i saw because
like so we don't buy a lot of ice cream
but i think the last time we bought some
we
bought some bluebell because they have
it at publix and i was actually kind of
impressed they had
you know because when i was growing up
it seemed like they only had you know
chocolate vanilla strawberry
you know swirl [ __ ] like that but it's
like they didn't have a lot of stuff
outside of that but
they have they do now yeah they had they
had coffee chocolate they had mint chip
they had
uh butter pecan rocky road the rocky
road great
the roc blue bell rocky road fantastic
uh blue bell nana puddin's good
it's got bananas in it and nilla wafer
cookies in it
i like their i like their mint chocolate
chip and i like their coffee flavor as
well
they also had a uh one with a little
peppermint remember that
little peppermint yeah it was kind of
like um
well wait was that the christmas one
that we got that had the candy cane
little candy canes in it because briars
makes a nice candy cane one too but they
only sell it uh
after thanksgiving or right around the
holidays you can't get it the rest of
the year i don't think
you can get fat eating bluebell lots and
lots of eggs in it
yeah it's very very fattening it's good
though that's why it's good yeah they
have they have their own creamery their
own dairy right there that's why
it's so good like that they're they're
they make it already because i feel like
if you're gonna eat ice cream just eat
ice cream because i know they have
i like frozen yogurt too but i know they
have that you know low fat or ice cream
and stuff like it but it's [ __ ] it's
like it melts and it's like this weird
consistency and it's like i don't know
it's just not as good bluebell's like
something you made at your house
yeah it is it tastes very homemade and
and you look at it and the packaging
looks generic
just solid colors nothing fancy
because it's a it's a [ __ ] you
advertising campaign
[ __ ] you you know what i mean yeah i
don't even think that the packaging is
like a different colors for the
different
flavors the whole thing is [ __ ] you
they're just beige
[ __ ] that's because the flavor of the
of the
of the ice cream uh speaks for itself
it doesn't need flashy packaging it's
it's not all the same like
it's yellow green or red or white
different colors brown
but there's no graphics on it yeah it
looks
just writing print yeah
i have to say that um that publix's uh
house brand of ice cream is also good
too yeah and they have it on sale a lot
of times and they have like a lot of
crazy
flavors it's similar to bluebell
actually it is yeah real similar not
quite as good but it's
it's up there we should bluebell we
should uh i think on
on next week's food show we should do
like a dessert show so we talked about
like the best ice cream and best candy
and all that kind of stuff that would be
fun wouldn't it unless you want to talk
about something else i don't know we'll
think about it
we can't think about it that far in
advance right it's going to want
bluebell sounds amazing look it up
you could probably find it or order it i
would think
it's like you know i've lived in the
south most of my life so it's very easy
to get here they even have it at
walgreens i think
like in the little freezer section
surprisingly you know i've
well it's been a while but you can order
ice cream
yeah they'll they'll bring it to you in
a little refrigerated refrigerator
things got dry
ice all around it yeah you can get it
you can per you can pretty much order
anything nowadays
like any food kind of you can even order
[ __ ] from restaurants like way across
the country
and they'll ship it to you so you know
yeah what a time to be alive
you can write pretty much whatever you
want that's all i need to talk about
all right he's done i'm done he's done
all right so well that's good because we
went on like 45 minutes so that's like
pretty good
that's about how long you said it was
going to be so that's awesome all right
so
it's tuesday today yeah so tomorrow uh
tomorrow evening at 5 p.m is our
wednesday
drunken party stream woohoo we don't
know what we're going to be talking
about we never know we're going to be
talking about we'll figure it out
we'll watch some [ __ ] tonight and talk
about that tomorrow or whatever i don't
know
but anyway thanks you guys for dropping
by on our little food show
and we will see you guys tomorrow
evening
at 5 00 pm bye